what's going on guys this is Rob and
black panther wakanda forever is coming
out here in the next few weeks at the
time that we're recording this video and
we are excited as I'm sure you are
because God man I feel like there's not
gonna be a dry eye in the house when
that movie comes out they do the whole
tribute to Chadwick Boseman man it's
gonna be rough it's gonna be rough man
but to celebrate the release of this
movie we're doing the top four best
moments most amazing epic moments of
Black Panther and Marvel Comics sure
there's more than that but honestly
everybody does top 10. so we want to do
something different this week but before
we get into that you may notice my
posters are different yes ladies and
gentlemen different posters behind me
and you're probably asking yourself Rob
those posters are ridiculously amazing
how do I get my hands on those posters I
have to have them well ladies and
gentlemen fortunately for you I am here
to help these posters were sent to me by
a company called display and we've made
a few Integrations with them so far
because their products are amazing now
what's display okay so you guys are
familiar going out buying posters
putting them in picture frames and
hanging the picture frames on the wall
after having to go through all the
hassle of putting nails on the wall and
making sure the nails are evenly spaced
and all that kind of stuff this plate
solves all those problems so check this
out
that black square up there that's a
magnet literally this is a metal picture
frame and it just holds it in place
foreign and now our artwork is up it's
literally that simple it's literally
just a little piece of paper that you
sit onto the wall you attach the magnet
to it and then you hang up your artwork
now here's the great thing about display
because I know a lot of the guys love
more than just comic books maybe you're
photographers maybe you're huge into
anime this plate has a colossal Library
so much so that it almost seems
impossible to sign a number to it but
they have a massive library that spans
all kinds of original artwork comic
books you've got Anime you've got Star
Wars you've got nature Landscapes cities
all kinds of different things so no
matter what kind of art you love you
will find it on that website now because
I'm so awesome and to help you all out
on your journey if you click the link in
the description if you order one to two
disc plates you'll get 32 off if you
order three or more disc plates you'll
get 38 off so make sure you guys check
the link in the description make sure
you guys go over to this plate and let's
get into our video
so kicking off our list of the most epic
moments in the history of Black Panther
in Marvel Comics and I know you guys are
gonna probably question me on this one
the fight between Eric hillmonger and
black panther no not the movie version
because in reality that fight wasn't
really that great and here's the reason
why when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I know it's probably
buhis buhis when it comes to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe their characters are
largely not comic book accurate and for
the most part we just sort of accept
that right like we in the comic book
community and even people who are
relatively familiar with Comics have all
kind of silently agreed that's okay
because the movies have just been really
really good so far so there's been no
reason to complain and with our number
four spot here the fight between Eric
killmonger and Black Panther in the MCU
and the fight between the two of them in
the comics is also different in the
Marvel Cinematic universes most of you
guys know when Black Panther fought Eric
killmonger he basically got rid of his
powers and it was designed to be an
honorable man-to-man hand-to-hand
counter fight what made the fight so
significant and what made me want to put
this on the the list is that when Eric
killmonger and black panther first
fought in Marvel Comics there were a few
things going on first and foremost Eric
hillmonger was every bit as smart as
black panther was the guy was an MIT
graduate guy had degrees like Advanced
degrees you wouldn't necessarily know it
because of just how brutal he appeared
and the fact that he seemed to be more
concerned with the power of Black
Panther in ruling wakanda than he did
exercising his intelligence and so on
and so forth but if you read between the
lines he was very very smart because not
only did he defeat black panther to rule
wakanda he beat Black Panther while
having no powers and black panther had
his powers and that's what made the
fight so epic imagine in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe if that fight took
place between Eric killemonger and
t'challa and killmonger was like no I
want to face you at your best I want to
fight you with your absolute best
because I want no one to doubt that when
I beat you you never had a chance to win
there was no Cathy out there was no if
this had happened differently no no and
that's how it was in the comics Eric
hillmonger overpowered black panther
despite black panther having his powers
that's how capable killmonger was the
fight was epic it was beautifully
written it's one of the most significant
moments in the history of the Black
Panther Mythos but coming in at number
three for those of you guys who want
like the more modern day take this when
we get into your list so number three on
this list is Black Panther leading an
army of zombies and it was amazing and
no this was not part of the original
Marvel Zombies Storyline this took place
during the single greatest run in the
history of all Comics Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers and Secret
Wars and in fact spoiler alert the rest
of the list does as well because that
story despite being called Avengers New
Avengers it's basically just a giant
black panther story so the thing about
this is that this took place during the
main Secret Wars event but there are
some things that happened that led up to
this so at the tail end of Jonathan
hitman's Fantastic Four fun he basically
tied into an event that had previously
happened known as do more doomorph was a
phenomenal story to give you the long
and short of it basically Dr Doom
orchestrated an Insurrection in wakanda
so that wakanda nationalists basically
ousted black panther as the ruler of
wakanda as well as his wife's storm
during that story t'challa was injured
so he basically passed the mantle of
black panther to shuri and that's how
sure he became the New Black Panther in
Marvel Comics but when Doctor Doom
orchestrated this Insurrection it was
all done for the purpose of giving him
the ability to sneak into wakanda steal
all of its vibranium and leave which he
successfully managed to do there were a
few other caveats like appeasing the
panther goddess bass and so on and so
forth but in order to defeat Doctor Doom
because of the fact that he had
Amplified his own magical energy using
the properties of vibranium that black
panther had to render all vibranium
across the world into just inert useless
chunks of rock and seemingly it
destroyed the wealth of wakanda he ended
up finding out later on that they had
bought countries national debt that's
our country's going to be paying them
back forever but in an effort to
basically find a new place for himself
in the Marvel Comics landscape and shuri
essentially becoming the New Black
Panther which was a role that he
couldn't just simply take back he met
with Reed Richards and then went down to
the necropolis where he met with the
panther goddess bass and that what ended
up happening is the Panther goddess bass
essentially foretold the events of
Avengers and New Avengers before they
haven't and basically said there was
going to be somebody who needed to be a
light in the dark and so what ended up
happening is vast bestowed to Chala with
a new kind of power that basically made
him a king of the Dead That's How in
Marvel Comics Black Panther is able to
communicate with his ancestors to talk
to other black panthers who have passed
on it's the fact that he's the king of
the Dead this all came to bear during
the events of Jonathan Hickman's Secret
Wars event when you basically had god
king Doom who was super powerful and the
superheroes that remained were launching
an attack against him that what black
panther had done as he had gone to to
the realm of Marvel Zombies thousands
upon thousands upon thousands of zombies
and because he was the king of the Dead
they had to obey his orders so he
basically seizes control of the Marvel
zombies and leads them into a battle
against Dr Doom it was
ridiculously epic it was just this just
insanely epic moment but he was only
able to do it because he was the king of
the dead but another really cool moment
that came out of really Secret Wars with
black panther is our number two spot
when Black Panther gets The Infinity
Gauntlet and that was so dumb because
that's never happened before in Marvel
Comics and it was just one of the most
epic moments ever so the idea behind
this is that when the Multiverse
basically died that you had Doctor
Strange you had Doctor Doom and you had
the molecule man Owen Reese Owen Reese
has nothing to do with this discussion
so you can ignore him the reality here
is that given the level of power that
belonged to the beyonders and they were
the ones who essentially destroyed the
Multiverse that power could be used to
basically save what was left and Doctor
Strange turned away from it because he
felt like it was too much power for one
man Dr Doom ever the guy who covets
insane amounts of power sees that power
for his own and then basically made
Doctor Strange his second in command but
Steven strange never fully trusted
Doctor Doom that distrust came to a head
when basically Steven strange helped out
the superheroes and Dr Doom destroyed
him but when this happened you ended up
having black panther along with name of
the Submariner who were basically led to
the Citadel of Doctor Strange by the
spiritual essence or the memory of
Stephen Strange who presented them with
The Infinity Gauntlet under the idea
that one it will not destroy Dr Doom
because he's more powerful than an
Infinity Gauntlet but it will turn the
tide of battle now the reason why the
Infinity Gauntlet even worked is because
the Infinity Stones that made up The
Gauntlet were collected from the
different universes that have been
brought together by Dr Doom when he
formed the new version of battle world
that took place or existed in secret
Wars from 2015 and because of the fact
that it was a singular place it was
quote unquote a universe unto itself it
allowed the Infinity Stones to work it's
just comic book logic but this moment in
and of itself it actually allowed for a
moment black panther to go Toe to Toe
with god king doom and it was an
impressive moment the funny thing about
it all is that even leading Marvel
Zombies against Doctor Doom and using
The Infinity Gauntlet on Doctor Doom it
was only ever a distraction and when
that Revelation came it was just an
amazing moment but that's not our number
one choice our number one choice for the
most epic moment of Black Panther the
coolest moment of Black Panther in
Marvel Comics the number one choice is
t'challa killing Namor the Submariner
kind of not really leave the name to die
on a world that black panther ended up
destruction so the important thing
behind this is this all has its roots
and basically Avengers versus X-men for
those of you guys who are curious why it
is that like fans always talk about the
feud between Black Panther and name of
the Submariner Avengers versus X-men is
when it starts the important thing about
this is basically the Phoenix Force
comes back Neymar gets a piece of it but
what he does he ends up basically
destroying a massive portion of wakanda
killing tons and tons of people and
literally black panther swears that he
will find a way to destroy Namor the
Submariner so what this does is it leads
to the start of the incursions right the
beginnings of the collapse of the
Multiverse and what ends up happening is
of course you do have the Illuminati
which is restored by black panther name
war is one of those guys you can tell
there's a massive rivalry there and
despite Namor kind of apologizing but
not really black panther doesn't care he
wants to kill him this goes into a story
called Infinity where basically the
forces of Thanos right Proxima midnight
the column sitting in corvus glaive all
those guys you saw them in Infinity war
and Avengers end game that they launched
an attack on Earth for a variety of
different reasons but during this time
one of the attacks take place on wakanda
and for the most part everybody's
defeated and because shuri is the Black
Panther at the time t'challa ends up
having to flee to meet with the
Illuminati but before he leaves shuri
remembers what it was that Namor did so
she presents black panther with the
ceremonial Dagger of the wakandan people
of the panther Clan and literally just
says put this where it belongs so what
you end up realizing is that the
Illuminati in order to Stave off the
incursions basically have to destroy
alternate Earths otherwise those Earths
will crash into the main Marvel Universe
Earth and both the universes will be
destroyed there's a whole reason behind
why it happens we don't need to go into
it here the important thing is there
comes a point when it's basically
Neymar's turn to destroy a world he
teleports down to this platform standing
above this alternate Earth with
literally an antimatter bomb that is
going to detonate but basically black
panther teleports down there with him
and like in that moment when it happens
you're like oh my God here we go because
he's got the dagger in his hand and it's
like oh my God here we go like this is
it man this is when Black Panther gets
his revenge and sure enough he does
right Namor is like so what do you plan
to do with that dagger and he's like you
realize you can't kill me with a knife
and it literally like black panther is
like no that's not what's going to kill
you I'm just putting this like I'm just
putting this dagger where it belongs and
so he just like plunges the dagger into
the chest of nameless Submariner like
literally hasn't knocked off the
platform by Blackpool like Blackboard
screams at him knocks him off the
platform Neymar goes crashing down and
so literally he's just laying there
right he's just laying on this alternate
Earth and like black panther has this
Detonator in his hand and black bulb is
basically like why why are you waiting
and the response of black panther is
that falls not going to kill Neymar the
Submariner he's too strong he's too
durable but it will leave him a little
phase and a little hazy for a while but
what I want is for him to wake up to
regain Consciousness and I want him to
know what's about to happen I want him
to know I'm gonna detonate this bomb and
he's going to die and literally Namor
starts to wake up starts to realize
what's happening and black panther
looking down on him detonates this
antimatter bomb and destroys the entire
world with Neymar on it the funny thing
about this is Black Panther didn't know
but Neymar actually survived and he was
saved by Thanos but with that being said
guys if you want to know anything about
the stuff that we've covered here in
this video make sure you guys check the
link in the description it'll send you
to a playlist where we cover it all
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers The New
Avengers run along with Secret Wars
which is the greatest black panther
story that's ever been told in the
history of Marvel Comics but thank you
all for watching and we will catch you
all later
peace